why do you choose the uh your love
bye-bye outfield as your walk-up song
well I used it in college and Georgia
Tech at Georgia Tech at college you know
like the 80s like pump up music you
listen to it a lot late night maybe okay
so that was like a big part of my life
there in college and it worked in
college and uh so I you know I figured
if it ain't broke don't fix it is that
your way of saying you were drunk when
you follow it okay I'm just know hydrate
you know keeping really well hydrated
okay well you guys got it I got it
now what do some of your teammates in
the clubhouse the Rockies think of that
nobody really likes it okay it's a you
know it's not like the coolest you know
it's not Drake it's not you know
whatever is on the radio right now but
that's good for me because I don't have
to change my song every year like keep
up with what's new so I just I just
stick with the class yeah right and and
it's working too
I mean whatever's working you stick with
it and is that the reason why again
you're leading I I don't want to do this
because I remember one time Paul O'Neill
when I was covering the World Series
once told an interview I won't reveal
because that person went ahead and asked
the question that Paul O'Neill before
the camera started said do not ask me
about my stats do not ask me about my
stats and the interviewers first
question was Paul you've had 400 in
these World Series with two home runs
and nine RBI and he just got so pissed
off is it wrong for me to mention your
standing I'm not I'm not a big with so
far to go left in the season you know I
don't like to do stats if you want to do
stats I'll give you the earmuffs okay
then you can and then but uh you know I
think it's it's you can't count your
kitchen chickens before the hats that
kind of thing you know I could always go
out tomorrow and stink it up but if you
have a TV show and I'm on your show they
do that no no no no you sure whatever
you like rich so you're saying that you
have no idea well we there's too many
numbers in baseball like I mean they put
it on this on the board I'm there but I
try
and stay away from the comparison you
know I don't like to look at my numbers
right next to someone under another
player and I just think that's bad you
know that's bad to be playing the game
you know for the numbers you know I'm
trying to win the game
[Music]
Marsha you team it you know that kind of
stuff I try not to focus on the numbers
yeah yeah sure did you never know
Marshall how many touchdowns you had or
rush hallway it in a game yeah oh yes
wait how many you knew how many yards
you needed for 100-yard games of course
yes I mean it's all about it you got to
know when you touched a football and
football you got to know like I'm having
a good game I'm getting four to five
yards every time I touched a football oh
I ripped off 420 yarder my god that was
like 40 right you know you know that's
why I was like when he said that I was
like now I understand a lot of the sort
of tradition in baseball I guarantee you
this and he was in a slump he would know
it's not as that's true
good rap Charlie Blackmon of the
Colorado Rockies here on the Rich Eisen
show so everybody's talking about the
team that you're playing in town that
you're in town to play tonight the
Dodgers Cubs win the World Series
everybody's wondering what's wrong with
the Cubs on occasion the Washington
Nationals will breakthrough in news
because Bryce Harper's got the exit
velocity of you know of spaceship
nobody's talking about the Colorado
Rockies Charlie what is the sense of
that in your Clubhouse uh I like it I
feel like I'm sneaking up on people you
know they're not going to be ready for
us so maybe we can catch them sleeping
and plus our market you know it's not
it's not la it's not even Washington so
and also we haven't been very good for a
while so it's easy for people though you
know it's hard to jump on the the
Rockies train at this point and I don't
blame them you know we we don't have the
track record of a lot of success as of
late but as the season progresses it
looks like we've got the pieces to do
something we haven't done in a while
so Bud Black is not utilizing the
nobody's respecting us card that hasn't
been played at all uh you know I think
with professionals I don't know that
that's you know I don't need extra
motivation to go out there and do my
best
um you know I don't think we really are
chomping at the bit because people you
know aren't talking about us in the
media you know that doesn't do much for
me okay because that's normally was
definitely what gets played in the
football world while you're shaking your
head over that's not blood Black's mo
that's just not that's not how he
operates that's that's a defensive
minded outset I would say that it's not
how buddy black operates he was me would
ya yeah he was with the Angels when I
covered the Angels and that's just not
that's not the social way that's not the
black way that's just not the way I
don't think it would ever right so you
think that Bud Black would never take
that approach with somebody like if you
know no I don't think so I think buds
real loose and relaxed you know played
the game for a long time I mean he's not
going to get bent out of shape about you
know this or that in the media or the
fact that people aren't talking about us
I mean he doesn't he's not buying into
that okay so every yes sir think people
are sleeping on the Rockies they are
it's just why do you think I mean
because they play a mile high what's it
like playing in Denver as a tar as a
football x-man like one week like what
do you notice differently there than you
would I had on once we play our first
game of the season in Denver and I felt
like I lost alone I mean you're a gamer
after we engage commit it's hard to
recuperate it it's tough it is tough
but that atmosphere is it's a challenge
to play in and I could imagine pitchers
who are not accustomed to pitching there
they wear down a lot faster hmm Charlie
Blackmon is here on the Rich Eisen show
studio so let's let's talk about the
package that is Charlie Blackmon right
now if you don't
say it looks like there is a mullet
that's going on in the back party in the
back and moulay havens friends a movie
ok a Moo leg and the beard that's going
on right now right what sort of
maintenance is required for this charlie
probably not as much as I should be
doing I'm like a coconut oil in the
morning I got some special wash mane and
tail kind of thing rub in there real
good and that's about it
ok and then there's the shirt that
you're wearing sort of a Hawaiian type
shirt right but here's a Dana's
dinosaurs all over the t-rex and a an RV
they go together do they I think a
Stegosaurus got those two and a cactus
right I'm sure I feel like it's very la
ish I have different shirts that I wear
to different parts of the country like I
have my my Southwest like Phoenix sure
okay you know I have like the Tommy
Bahama so what's the San Diego shirt and
if I'm going to LA I want to be like so
you grab this shirt prior to leaving on
the road trip saying that's my LA
Charolais sure like where are you
heading next we are going to San
Francisco so what is your San Francisco
jacket just a jacket it's like a sport
coat like a flannel keep myself warm
because it shouldn't be this cold in the
summer yeah but the phrase that's the
phrase the coldest winter ever spent was
a summer in San Francisco at that time
Charlie would you mind giving rich a
shirt like that I think it's birthday is
tomorrow you know you know it's rich
aizen's birthday you can do that we can
do that hey I'm not asking for the shirt
off your back I think I'm kind of asking
for the shirt off your back I kind of
just look at this great shirt you don't
think I should go crazy I think they
would go crazy but the man doesn't have
a shirt other Walker Nayla I don't think
so never good good TV yeah we make for
good TV show octagon [ __ ] okay I like it
who's the UH that what's the toughest
team that you face this year so fun huh
I don't like to give anybody too much
credit okay
I thought the Nationals were a good team
and when we played them they have a lot
of big you know big name starting
pitchers and they have a lot of guys
swinging the bat really well you know
Bryce Harper Zimmerman is having a
really good season over at first base I
know he's you know had some injury
history and there in the past but he's
got it together this year and he's an
offensive force right now he's the ball
juiced what do you think I'm gonna say
no because I'm a hitter but how many
home runs do you have Charlie I have 16
did he know how do you know well I just
you know the Homer home runs like I said
you know like you know you can I can
forget all the other stuff but you know
how many touchdowns to get because
that's you know that's the one stat that
matters about the WWE had out yesterday
was literally on a tape it looked like
you were swinging a golf club by
swinging that one out of the park
yeah sure honestly that's that's bad
baseball you should not be swinging and
because there's that close to bouncing
that was a little bit lucky there unless
you're hitting it out of court
I mean Brett if you hit it out of the
park then so you know it's okay but
usually you swing and miss at that and
then you last night though um and I
don't know if we have it in the LA
broadcasting center to show but last
night
Robinson Cano with the bases loaded in
Seattle and you know Safeco is no joke
to poke something out of there right he
hit a fly ball or he hit me he swings
the bat and he he he ducks his head
which is the international symbol of I
just missed it yeah and the ball kept
going for a grand slam home run oh that
stinks
yeah thing I hate homers I know but but
to me that was the most juiced ball
moment that I've seen you know it's just
a ball that a professional hitter yeah
you know when you've just missed it
correct I usually I'm good at that right
you know what I mean but so that's when
I saw that last night I thought to
myself that was the most 20-17 moment
I've seen and I'm not taking anything
away from you the way that you know
alright you are rich am I really doing
yes that has 16 home runs and you're
asking is the ball juice so I mean your
your pennant charlie I you know I think
it's everybody wants to believe that
they're getting better but that you know
that's where you know my instinct Kano's
instincts he's played the game for 10
years as a big leaguer you know he
probably has a good idea of when he's
hit hit the ball well enough to get over
the fence so that I mean that makes me
wonder but you know maybe though you
know the winds blowing out that night or
maybe it's shirts warmer you know
there's a lot of factors that go into
you know there's been lots of times
where I've hit a ball and I said hey
that's definitely going out and then it
doesn't you know no so I don't feel too
bad about not thinking one gets out okay
hold on wait has it happened to you two
other way have you hit a ball and was
like oh that's a pop oh one ah yes in in
New York like right field where the
Yankees play it can kind of you it looks
like it's far out there but then you hit
one in the air and it's not sure like or
she keeps creeping in on you beam sure
that already happens in Colorado when
you hit one in there and you're like oh
that's not going well it'll happen but
the thing about collar up you know
nobody gives us credit like it's 415
people nothing to feel yessiree so here
in LA I think it's 399 you know that so
but not when Cano gets back to the
dugout does he admit that I thought I
missed it where does he come back and
said you a new ahead you go you got to
pretend like you know your pops
Carolee he's bitter because Cano is not
wearing pinstripes oh he can't handle it
when a player does well post Yankee
career I've just been chopped down to
size for all three hours of this show
mmm you asked me to come in honey I did
I actually I have a day job I know that
every single moment I just keep getting
cut down to size by the way Charlie you
want to hear a window into Marshall how
he sees the field when you're talking
about your stats and all that Marshall
could tell you right now how many steps
that would taste good
the room before getting out of a seat
that's the difference well in this room
is exactly ten yards away the couch
that's a first down marker I think I
need when you just walk it off you want
to do that right now let's walk it off
go ahead charlie black we're gonna get
up good will open up his mic let's walk
it off Vanir Vanir that couch over there
that couch you know what ten ten ten
yards would be okay I think I got it
okay I'll be the official Charlie
Blackmon one two three four five six
seven eight nine that's ridiculous is
that ten is that ten yards Charlie first
down and you gotta know that I feel like
an otter frag that's hmm that's really
good
have to all right now at Marshall what's
four hundred and fifty feet away from us
right now no no idea
okay no it's the robinson cano grand
that's right but he thought wasn't
leaving are done so you're taking on the
Dodgers tonight then in San Francisco
I'm N and then beyond good luck to you
Charlie thanks I'm coming in here to
appreciate you taking the time and
getting out of your hotel room and
getting that beard all ready for herself
but I said hello he's the fellow San
Diego State Aztecs oh yeah coach down in
San Diego for a long time I see him all
the time yeah yeah please do let him
know good to see you Charlie Blackmon is
here all 16 of his home runs the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country
and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy